on his first year wanted to address both
healthcare and clinic and he could only
get one signature issue accomplished it
was obviously health care he didn't get
to do climate change you may only get
one shot in your first issue that you're
going to push you get one shot that it
may be the only thing you get past what
is that first issue for your presidency
Eric swallow your first for parkland for
Orlando for every community affected by
gun violence ending gun violence
senator vinegar climate change in the
lack of economic mobility Bernie talks
about Senator Jeffery passing a family
Bill of Rights that includes a national
paid leave plan universal pre-k
affordable daycare and making sure that
women and families can thrive in the
workplace no matter who they are so
passing a middle class and working
families tax cut daca guns for the first
thing you said the tax cut apprentice
that there's only one or two issues out
there to enormous crises senator Jenner
a political revolution people have got
to stand off and take on the special
interest we could transform this country
fine Vice President Biden your first
issue mr. vice president I think you're
so underestimated with Barack Obama dude
he's the first man to bring together the
entire world 196 nations to commit to
deal with climate change immediately
[Applause]
but first the first thing I would do is
make sure that we defeat Donald Trump
okay period there boo digits your first
priority your first issue as president
that you were going to block and tackle
we've got to fix our democracy before
it's too late get that right climate
immigration taxes
every other issue gets better mr. mr.
Gannon I would pass a $1,000 freedom
dividend for every American adult
starting at age 18 which would speed us
up on climate change because if you get
the boot off of people's throats they'll
focus on climate change much more clear
governor Hickenlooper I will do a
collaborative approach to climate change
and I would pronounce it well before the
election to make sure we don't react the
worst president in American history and
Ms Williams New Zealand who said that
her goal is to make New Zealand the
place where it's the best place in the
world for a child to grow up and I will
tell the girlfriend you were so on
because the United States of America is
going to be the best place in the world
for a child to grow up thank you you
guys were close with the short at least
it was shorter no response not at all
all right c-minus